on l'entend tous les jours la télé
l'humanité se dirige vers un futur
sombre nous sommes quasi 8 milliards sur
terre et pour beaucoup c'est trop mais
est ce que c'est vrai combien dumas
maximum la terre pourra-t-elle supporter
combien de temps et à quel prix sur
cette planète dans la nuit ou partout la
lumière jaillit on pourrait croire que
l'humanité grue de partout en aurait pas
tant que ça s'ils ont rassemblé tous les
humains en france avec un mètre carré
pour chacun on tiendrait dans sept mille
huit cents kilomètres carrés
c'est plus petit que l'île de france la
population chinoise entière tiendrait
dans le val d'oise
si on voulait parquet la population
mondiale dans un building aux dimensions
standard vous pourriez mettre 2500
personnes par étage ce qui nous donne
une tour de 3 millions cent vingt mille
étage ce qui ferait quasi la même taille
que la terre
bon on est d'accord qu'un mètre carré
par personne faut espérer que nos
voisins faute pas trop c'est pas vivable
imaginons plutôt la vie dans une ville
où toute l'humanité se rassembler pour
ça alors au bangladesh dans la ville de
dakar c'est la ville la plus densément
peuplé du monde
quarante mille habitants au kilomètre
carré huit fois plus que lille ou
marseille les rues de dacca groupe de
gens les claques sans son incessant il
n'y a pas un seul endroit où vous pouvez
être seul en moyenne chaque habitant n'a
que 23 mètres carrés pour vivre juste
l'enfer tout ceci n'est pas sans
rappeler un film de science fiction bien
connu soleil vers un monde surpeuplé
rationner affamés où on évacue les
marées humaines à la tractopelle
je vous propose un petit exercice de
pensée sur terre on est d'accord tout
n'est pas habitable mer les déserts les
glaciers on va retirer ça nous laisse
134 millions de kilomètres habitable 25%
la terre et bien si on applique et la
densité de la ville de dakar sur toute
cette surface
nous pourrions tenir à presque 6000
milliards d'habitants par rapport à
aujourd'hui
il ya de la marge dans l'histoire le
maximum d'habitants au mètre carré dans
une ville a été atteint au japon 5300
habitants salaire assez peu mais sur une
île qui faisait la taille d'à peine huit
stades de foot on était à équivalent de
84 mille habitants kilomètres carrés en
appliquant ces chiffres à toute la
surface habitable terrestre on
obtiendrait un maximum supportable de
onze mille milliards d'habitants sur
terre comme sur l'île
chaque habitant n'aurait que 12 m² pour
vivre ça à l'air clock dit comme ça mais
c'est déjà la réalité pour beaucoup de
français
moi même j'ai vécu presque dix ans à
paris dans une chambre de bonne de 9
mètres carrés mais j'en suis pas devenu
fou pour autant enfin je crois
si on reprend notre image de tout à
l'heure les 8 milliards d'êtres humains
qui tient dans l'équivalent de sept
mille huit cents kilomètres carrés
si on appliquait cette densité à toute
la surface habitable la terre pourrait
supporter 134 mille milliards de
personnes voilà la limite maximale
théorique
le truc c'est que ce chiffre vous
envoûter il est mathématiquement
impossible à atteindre
la population sic roulera bien avant il
faut bien se nourrir boire disposer
d'énergie ce qui change totalement notre
problématique c'est pas combien
d'humains maximum sur terre mais combien
d'humains maximum peuvent vivre des
ressources de la terre en 300 ans nous
sommes passés de 1 à 8 milliards
d'individus
la croissance de la population mondiale
actuelle et à 1,12 pour cent ça paraît
peu mais attention ça s'accumule le et
1,12 % s'appliquant aussi aux nouvelles
naissances pour finir en courbe
exponentielle
du coup si on ajoute encore 300 ans avec
cette même courbe
apa addis pas à 20 mais bien à 300
milliards d'individus sur terre
ouais là c'est chaud dans un tel monde à
quoi ressemblerait nos vies au niveau de
la nourriture c'est pas glorieux
on va devoir se partager toute la
production mondiale en 300 milliards ce
qui laisserait pas plus d'une dizaine de
kilos de nourriture par personne par an
pire chaque humain devra se satisfaire
d'un pauvre kilos de viande par an
maximum
autant vous dire que les entrecôtes de
500 grammes vous oubliez pour l'eau
c'est pas mieux on consomme 4 7 mille
milliards de litres d'eau par an et on
est d'accord c'est déjà bien la galère
c'est frêche instruction et bien pour
une planète à 300 milliards d'habitants
il en faudrait mille fois plus par jour
pour nous sauver de cette situation il
faudrait dessaliniser massivement l'eau
des océans ce qui est très très
énergivores or avec notre production
énergétique actuelle on n'aurait que 2,5
kilowattheure a partagé par personne et
par an ce qui représente pour une année
230 expresso à la machine à café
en réalité dans ces conditions la
population mondiale s'auto réguler
naturellement par manque de ressources
les habitants mourrez de faim de soif
jusqu'à retrouver un équilibre
ça serait terrible obligé de laisser
mourir des gens pour que l'humanité
survivent et bien ce dilemme moral
faudra que tu le fasses de ton vivant
car nous sommes en plein dedans 2000n
xxx la grande régulation
vous connaissez tous le jours de
dépassement cette date dans l'année à
partir de laquelle nous vivons à crédit
où l'on a consommé plus de ressources
que ce que la terre peut produire en un
an par exemple si vous coupez mille
arbres alors que la terre ne renouvelle
que 500
c'est parce que vous avez coupé des
arbres qui sont là depuis longtemps or
cette réserve n'est pas illimitée en
2021 le genre de dépassement est tombé
le 5 mai ouais c'est rapide pourtant il
ya encore quelques années en 1970 le
jour de dépassement tombé près de noël
en 1960 on arrive une même pas consommé
la moitié de ce que la terre produisent
et en un an on était deux fois moins
nombreux dans le monde et nos problèmes
actuels
nos grands parents ne les avaient pas
certains économistes estiment que 5
milliards et la population idéal
terrestre pour ménager les ressources
mais il ya un gros défaut dans leurs
calculs
c'est qu'il inclue
les inégalités entre pays les pays
riches ne représente que 17% la
population mondiale et consomme pourtant
plus que les 83 % restants si on voulait
être égalitaire et que tout le monde sur
terre puisque vivant comme un américain
sans dépasser nos ressources
on serait limitée à 1,9 milliard
d'individus
c'est chaud alors c'est quoi nos
solutions certains proposent la
décroissance
si le monde entier vivait plus
simplement limité l'industrie retourner
à la terre alors oui nous pourrions long
terme
11 milliards sans problème mais bon vous
êtes beaucoup à penser comme cartman
deuxième solution le malthusianisme en
gros la réduction de population alors
non on va pas cela choix-là gengis khan
le bout a quand même réussi à éradiquer
12% de la population mondiale pendant
son règne
non la réduction de population c'est
quelque chose de sérieux c'est même au
programme des nations unies ou par
contre je vous arrête tout de suite ça
veut pas dire qu'ils vont créer des
guerres ou un super virus mortel
c'est plutôt des programmes pour réduire
en douceur la natalité
par exemple un député écologiste
proposer une grève des ventres avec
suppression des allocations familiales
après le deuxième enfant
le problème c'est que ce genre
d'idéologie elle passe moyens il ya la
religion il ya la méfiance contre les
gouvernements et il ya les tensions
ethniques qui monte qui font se dire à
certains qu'on fait la guerre par les
ventres par le nombre de naissances qui
en démocratie donne un nombre de votants
et donc une victoire politique sur le
long terme
et puis plus sérieusement même quand on
veut appliquer ce genre de politique ça
marche pas la chine pendant 25 ans à
pratiquer la politique de l'enfant
unique
ça a produit un désastre ont caché les
enfants les privant de soins d'éducation
ont tué les petites filles jusqu'à avoir
un petit garçon qui perpétuera la lignée
familiale et le pompon c'est que malgré
tout ça la population a quand même
augmenté 400 millions de personnes en
plus alors même que les règles se
durcissent et je prendrai pas ce chiffre
pour dire que c'est un échec
ça n'a pas marché c'est pour ça que les
politiques préfèrent la méthode douce en
passant par l'éducation des femmes
particulièrement en accédant des voix
professionnelle enrichissante
elles auront moins envie en saurons plus
contrainte à se dédier une vie de mère
l'argument de l'écologie est presque là
pour se
justifiée à soi même après je vais vous
avouer tout ceci lots incertain et pas
forcément efficace
en réalité le seul moyen de sauver la
planète c'est la science
alors oui elle est très décrié
aujourd'hui on dit qualité biologique
marque ethniquement outils du
gouvernement mais les gars c'est elle
qui va sauver vos enfants de la famille
la nourriture par exemple je vous
apprends rien si je vous dis que la
viande écologiquement ça consomme bien
là dessus la science cherche des
solutions vient de synthétique steak
d'insectes shaker de protéines comme
fidh ou de l'hémoglobine végétal qui
donne à l'âme possible mythe par exemple
de vraies sensations sanguine celle de
mordre dans un steak qu'alors que c'est
que des légumes
maintenant s'il s'avérait que le monde
n'était pas prêt à baisser sa
consommation carnée il resterait
l'amélioration des rendements par
l'utilisation d'eau j'aime ou de fermes
verticales gérer technologiquement
chaque année c'est minimum un demi
milliard de tonnes de nourriture qui est
perdu en ballade i et catastrophes
climatiques
une entreprise comme agricole qui fait
grandir des fraises en conteneurs n'a
pas ce problème
ces prêts sont parfaites toute l'année
maintenant une telle méthode ça
demanderait d'énergie ça c'est le gros
gros gros problème en france dites vous
que même avec nos centrales nucléaires
on est tout juste niveau électricité en
hiver
la faute à la surconsommation des
grandes villes mais aussi à la méthode
d'acheminement et de stockage qui
conduit à des pertes immenses chaque
1500 km parcouru la moitié de
l'électricité est perdu dans les files
une situation qui ne peut qu'empirer si
comme le laisse penser la tendance
politique du moment on se tourne vers
l'éolien ou le solaire
c'est d énergie beaucoup plus
imprévisible demandant des normes
infrastructures de stockage pour quand
le soleil ou le vent se fait absent par
exemple à tout hasard la nuit en hiver
quand on a le plus besoin d'électricité
c'est une catastrophe écologique à
construire avec l'utilisation de terreur
c'est quasi impossible à recycler et au
final l'allemagne qui a fait l'erreur de
se tourner vers cette solution s'est
lourdement endetté auprès de la chine
pour construire ces éoliennes pour qu'au
final leur production énergétique ton
banni
si bas qu'ils sont obligés de rouvrir
les mines de charbon
bravo pour sauver la planète vous êtes
devenu le plus gros pollueurs d'europe
le pétrole vous en parle même pas en
2050 si on aura quasiment plus ou du
moins il sera trop cher à extraire pour
être rentable non la seule vraie énergie
renouvelable qui marche aujourd'hui
c'est l'hydraulique et pour ça il faut
accepter de construire des barrages donc
de noyer des forêts entières détruire
des écosystèmes est risqué comme en
chine des ruptures de barrages qui
conduisent à des centaines de milliers
de morts ça tombe bien en vue dans notre
scénario on est en surpopulation
alors oui il reste le nucléaire c'est
l'énergie qui fait le moins de morts il
ya pas qu co2 ça produit énormément
d'électricité
sur papier c'est nickel mais c'est pas
non plus illimité le combustible est
gros cyclable grâce aux box mais c'est
pas un fou
les filons du radium exploitables
représente 5 millions de tonnes ce qui
permettrait au rythme actuel de fournir
de l'électricité jusqu'en 2070 pour les
plus pessimistes 2250 selon l'aena en
supputant la découverte de nouveaux
filons minier et l'amélioration des
techniques de recyclage
en réalité si en 2090 les humains soient
de vivre avec notre niveau de confort et
qu'une solution prier que la fusion
nucléaire marche produire des mini
soleil sur terre le jour où c'est ok
les problèmes énergétiques de l'humanité
disparaissent il ya des projets comme
iter bc expérimental on n'est pas sûr
qu'un jour ça puisse marcher et c'est le
constat le plus terrible affaire il faut
réussir ou périr alors évidemment il ne
faut pas être qu'à sambre crions-nous
est paniquée beaucoup d'influenceurs
joue sur vos peurs pour vous vendre du
discours et des programmes politiques
nous emporter sur cette génération le
poids de la culpabilité d'exister ça
finit avec la fp qui fait le bilan
carbone d'un bébé face à ce
catastrophisme de plus en plus de
personnes renoncent et préfèrent vivre à
fond vianne grosses bagnoles foutu pour
foutu comme l'orchestré du titanic
jouant dans un bateau qui coule
autant profiter à fond il existe
probablement l'antre-2 celui de l'action
politique de la technologie des petits
gestes qui permettent de gagner du temps
jusqu'à trouver de nouvelles solutions
énergétiques et alimentaires
on y arrivera on y est toujours arrivé
pourquoi ne réveillons nous pas d'un
scénario de stations spatiales ou de
changement de planète
j'ai pas la solution
personne n'est devin mais je peux vous
parler d'un petit geste possible votre
téléphone
composé de plus 70 matériaux extraits
aux quatre coins du monde
vous en doutez ça crache alors au lieu
de le jeter au bout d'un an parce que
vous l'avez cas c'est pourquoi ne pas le
protéger
oui transition idéale pour vous
introduire le sponsor de cette vidéo
les coques rhino shield vous connaissez
la résistance de leurs matériaux anti
choc plein de vie des as ont tenté de le
détruire
ça marche pas fonctionner si ça peut
vous permettre de rallonger ne serait ce
que d'un an la durée de vie de votre
téléphone
c'est un petit geste qui fait du bien en
plus il ya plein de design méga stylet
greenshield travail avec un tas
d'artistes indépendants et des licences
officielles comme harry potter et ken
morty one piece mayereau academia et
pour les scientifiques il ya même design
approuvé par la nasa pour vous on a un
coupon de réduction avec le code silence
trash vous pouvez bénéficier de 10% de
réduction pendant 48 heures le lien dans
la description
dépêchez vous en réalité qu importe ce
que nous faisons l'humanité survivre à
sa soeur à part la technologie par le
changement des mentalités avec la hausse
des prix au moins enviable par les
guerres pour les ressources par la
famine pour les perdants ça sera pas
agréable mais comme disait le professeur
mal comme la vie trouve toujours un
sonar
[Musique]